[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 11 septembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale tout de suite les
titres de cette édition et de
toussus-le-noble à versailles nature et
découverte va déménager son siège dans
la cité royale au printemps 2010 9
le groupe spécialisé dans les produits
de bien-être va s'installer dans une
ancienne halle ferroviaire de la gare
des chantiers le quartier environnant
est en pleine réhabilitation
ne l'appelez plus commanderie des
templiers mais tout simplement la
commanderie le lieu historique
d'elancourt a fait peau neuve pour sa
nouvelle saison d'ailleurs le coup de
coeur culture du jour sera consacré à
l'une de ses expositions c'est à la fin
de ce journal
enfin le refuge spa de plaisir au coeur
d'un documentaire réalisé par la chaîne
ces huit c'est la première partie a été
diffusée vendredi dernier un bon coup de
projecteur pour le site qui a vécu un
été difficile en raison du nombre
d'abandons d'animaux
elle nous faisons le bilan avec neil
andrew f chef d'equipe au refuge de
plaisir elle nous parlons aussi tout à
l'heure d'un anniversaire attrape la
ville fait 50 ans de jumelage avec la
commune tchèque de coprim nice le
conseil de surveillance de la société du
grand paris connaît son nouveau patron
l'élu de seine saint denis patrick
braouezec a été désigné président
vendredi
pour rappel la sgp est en charge du
projet du grand paris express ces
nouveaux métros déployés dans la région
est dès les années 2020
une élection qui ne passe pas auprès des
sept présidents des départements
franciliens également membre du conseil
de surveillance
ils dénoncent une élection nominations
opérées par l'état par conséquent ces
derniers ont boycotté le vote
vendredi les élus d'île de france
militait pour une candidature de pierre
bédier président du département des
yvelines le quartier des chantiers à
versailles en pleine mutation c'est au
tour de l'ancienne halle ferroviaire de
la gare de connaître un renouveau
entièrement à réhabiliter elle
accueillera d'ici le printemps 2010 9 le
nouveau siège de nature et découvertes
marylène iapichino est allé visiter le
chantier d'une halle ferroviaire il n'en
reste que la charpente métallique
dans sa réhabilitation du quartier des
chantiers la mairie de versailles a
trouvé en nature et découvertes
une enseigne spécialisée dans les
produits de bien-être et de lien avec la
nature
fondée en 1990 l'entreprise idéale pour
s'y installer
pas question pour autant de détruire ces
vestiges du passé et j'ai donc décidé
très tôt de prendre deux bâtiments tel
qu'il était de construire un bâtiment en
bois qui viennent le confort t il
quelque chose qui demanderaient épauler
un vieux bâtiment dans la commune entend
dès qu' une béquille avec un nouveau
matériau le clt comparable un
contreplaqué plus épais il est composé
de pins blancs du nord et permet de
construire des bâtiments de grande
hauteur
plus de 3000 mètres carrés sur trois
étages en bois pour un effet très nature
avec également des panneaux
photovoltaïques sur le toit
on est dans la grande tradition de l'adn
de nature à découvert c'est à dire de
l'écologie la nature et d'écologie pas
d'accord ce bâtiment est totalement
écologique
et puis derrière nous avons dans la
chance d'avoir des jardins qui nous ont
été données en concession par la ville
de versailles pour faire d un potager en
permaculture car la fondation nature et
découvertes installe avec son siège un
jardin permaculture une aux mails pour
le maire de versailles qui souhaitait
installer un potager dans sa ville mais
manquer de financements
on a trop souffert des ces villes
dortoirs côté de paris ici c'est une
ville avec son urbanité avec sa
complexité
et aujourd'hui on montre que à côté de
ce coeur de ville il peut y avoir des
jardins les travaux vont se poursuivre
jusqu'au printemps 2010 9 et
l'entreprise espère s'y installer au
mois de mai un demi siècle d'histoire en
commun la ville de trappes fête ses 50
ans de jumelage avec coprim nice en
république tchèque en août une
délégation trappistes s'est rendu sur
place mais deux invités étaient du
voyage hani lelieur bonsoir alors
comment on prononce coprim nice en check
up fini tu vois là c'est un peu mieux
vous êtes président du comité de
jumelage de trappes également avec nous
en plateau cheikh naïm bonsoir soir vous
êtes deuxième maire adjoint de la ville
de trappes en charge de la vie
démocratique et associatives 50 ans de
jumelage avec une ville étrangère qu'est
ce que ça représente pour
pour la ville de trappes beaucoup de
choses merci je voudrais d'abord
remercier nos maires guy malandain
prévient le maire honoraire de traber
marigot et le maire de copenhague
d'avoir ménagé aucun effort pour porter
ce projet 50 ans c'est pas cinq points
séparent cinq jours c'est une preuve que
ce projet a été porté par des
institutions que sont ouverts par des
hommes par des formes par des
associations qui est le comité du
jumelage
c'est une preuve que c'est un projet qui
porte à coeur nos deux peuples
dellal public et des trappistes 50 ans
annie le lire avec une signature en plus
c'est un contrat d'amitié entre les deux
vielles finalement c'est le
renouvellement de ceux de ce jumelage
l'histoire va se poursuivre avec cette
ville tchèque qui bien sûr bien sûr
c'est un de nous avons plusieurs
jumelages attrape et le jumelage a copié
initiés c'est vraiment le jumelage qui
vit intensément ont deux échanges
parfois par an beaucoup de trac piste
connaissent notre ville jumelle comme
chez lindsay et tchèques quand il nous
rend compte dans la rue ne reconnaissent
donc c'est assez amusant d'ailleurs et
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai pari
d'amitié parce que 50 ans est aussi
beaucoup d'histoires beaucoup de
changements dans les régimes même
politique du pays et donc forcément
c'est un peu comme un mariage avec des
concessions des discussions et puis
malgré tout on continue et on continue
pour les habitants des échanges
réguliers vous l'avez dit on précise que
coprim lycée situé à l'est de la
capitale tchèque prague à plus de 20000
habitants sur place après vingt mille
habitants le coeur de la ville au départ
c'est la construction des camion tatra
qui ont gagné plusieurs paris-dakar
manière depuis et en fait c'est un peu
c'est un peu là sochaux la souche au
tchèque
oui avec la construction de ces nocives
et camions et attrapes il y à il y avait
à l'époque
l'importateur de ses camions d'où la
signature du premier du premier jumelage
qui était un élan du un accord avec le
maire les usines tatra lusine ce trajet
re qui importait les camions tâte raf
tout ça est fondé sur quand même une
histoire importante aujourd'hui une rue
coco prive nice actuellement il ya une
rupture ni ses ouïes à train
j'ai continué le plus prononcé en
français ça va être dur pour moi on va
vous inviter au cours de tchèque
l'invitation est entendue chaque année
ça représente quoi pour la ville
finalement télé l'importance de
développer de d'entretenir des liens
avec avec des deals étrangères des
villes européennes ou même du monde
beaucoup de sous donc l'ouverture vers
l'international d'abord des relations
fondées sur la paie des formes là des
relations fondées sur l'amour et des
relations fournée entre les jeunes
trappistes les jeunes tchèques le long
d'une ville c'est de mettre en pratique
de mettre en liquide tout cela lui
disant on voit notamment à l'image des
jeunes de cech qui était vu attrapé lia
il a 2 ans 1/2 16 montées en projet ce
qu'on appelle le projet erasmus entre
nos amitiés polonais est l'objet était
de dire que nous avions nous en tant que
tapie son conseil des jeunes il ya bien
considérer la république tchèque
il y en avait pas un en pologne et les
avions dit nous allons fédérer no france
nous allons nous allons échanger et
aider nos jeunes polonais à mettre en
place un conseil des jeunes c'est dans
ce sens que nous sommes retrouvés
d'abord dans un premier temps attrape un
séjour de quatre jours
douze étapes lycées se sont rendus en
république tchèque en compagnie des
jeunes polonais est l'objet était de
travailler ensemble
de sorte qu'on puisse installer
également notre conseil des jeunes et
c'est pas le seul jumelage de trappes
trap est également jeu mais est une
ville italienne castiglione del lago là
l'accent et est plus assurée quelles
missions en fait vous quelles sont les
missions d'un comité de jumelage dans
l'entretien dont on va dire de ses
relations avec les villes étrangères
l'émission l'émission sont avant tout de
lier les populations les habitants de
les faire connaître de choisir tes des
objectifs communs des rencontres bon
mois d'octobre là on reçoit de
délégation culturelle une italienne une
tchèque et donc
ben je pense que ça va être un moment
joyeux et festif
donc c'est surtout ça et puis aussi
des moments sportifs des clubs qui est
le sport qui se rencontrent ça passe de
l'escrimé au football de pas de rugby
malheureusement les tchèques pratique
peu le rugby mais et pelé ce crime mais
on n'a vu venir venir des hockeyeurs qui
ont reçu les escrimeurs donc voilà on
met on mélange les équipes
une dernière chose c'est une actualité
ce sera le 18 septembre la ville de
trappes va signer avec le comité de
jumelage et l'association des
ressortissants denis risque une ville du
sénégal a va signer la convention
qu'est ce que ça va mettre en place
cette convention alors cette convention
va mettre en place la ville d'étape
s'est engagée résolument vers
l'international il est depuis trois ans
un quart nous soutenons donc toutes les
actions en faveur du monde
du tiers-monde et nous avions mis en
place ce qu'on appelle un appel à projet
parce que nous avons à peu près 150
associations sur la ville il était plus
difficile pour nous d'apporter une
subvention pour aller à l'international
et nous avons voulu être juste en disant
on fait un appel à projets l'appel à
projets ou les associations peuvent
démissionner et il ya un jury qui décide
et qui dit cette association la a
remporté pendant trois ans va faire un
projet avec nous et la ville a délégué
le cadre du jumelage esma poursuivre
toutes ces questions techniques avec
l'association est donc cette année nous
avions il ya trois ans c'était au congo
ont posé qui a été très très très de
manager for notable sur poteaux et cette
année c'est une réflexion d'une case de
santé au sénégal dans la région du
sénégal oriental avec l'association des
ressources et s'indigne éric d'un coup
qui va démarrer on va signer le vendredi
18 à 18 l appréhension tripartite le
vendredi à 18 septembre merci à vous
deux ani le hir présidente du comité de
jumelage et chaque année de deuxième
maire adjoint de la ville de trappes
merci d'avoir été avec nous c'est une
tradition pour les communes et
d'ailleurs trappe n y échappe pas au
moment de la rentrée scolaire se déroule
les forum des associations le week-end
dernier à plusieurs villes de saint
quentin en yvelines organiser leurs
événements des associations sportives
culturelles et caritatives tout était au
rendez vous reportage à magny les
hameaux et du en cours de mélanie poquet
et nicolas landry la voix est signée
michael ennemis devront trouver son
sport son activité culturelle ou
s'engager pour une cause un casse tête
pour les visiteurs des forums
d'associations à magny les hameaux 90
structures sont actives près de 250
bénévoles étaient présents pour animer
cet événement ça permet d'avoir la
visibilité
mine de rien
c'est important aussi que les nouveaux
les nouvelles personnes qui arrivent
donc sur man in arnaud sache que il ya
du basket à côté du sport les
associations caritatives présentent leur
mission c'est le cas de la marche à
suivre qui organise des marots tous les
dimanches un objectif cette foire trade
association de manière transversale
j'ai pris des contacts avec
l'association vestiaire qui elle
justement travailler sur la récupération
de vêtements pour pouvoir les
redistribuer aux personnes qui en ont
besoin donc du coup ça permettrait de
créer comme comme cet exemple-là des
collaborations c'est très intéressant la
vie associative un enjeu politique
majeur pour les communes et quelques
difficultés sur le renouvellement des
bénévoles qu'on a c'est d'accompagner au
mieux en proposant des formations on
travaille sur une école du bénévolat
pour essayer de former les nouvelles
générations bénévolat mais plus maman a
plutôt dynamique qui on essaie
d'accompagner son dynamisme
c'est important parce que ça permet
aussi aux guyancourt toit de pouvoir se
rencontrer du pouvoir participer à une
session de ne pas être isolé c'est le
vivre ensemble c'est pour ça
effectivement c'est quelque chose auquel
on tient énormément nous la municipalité
de favoriser la création d'associations
ou la cua la pérennité de certaines des
associations en soutien en 2018 est
municipalité de guyancourt consacre près
de 16 % de ses dépenses à ce poste
budgétaire pour magny les hameaux la
somme atteint plus de 230 mille euros
des militants de la cause animale
condamné quatre membres de l'association
269 libération animale ont été copiés
d'une amende de 3000 euros sanction
prononcée par le tribunal correctionnel
de versailles pour violation de domicile
en avril dernier ces activistes était
parti faisait partie des 66 personnes à
s'introduire en pleine nuit à l'abattoir
pour st aguy arrondies ou dans militants
et personnels de l'établissement était
en étaient venus aux mains et dans un
communiqué l'association a dénoncé un
jugement particulièrement sévère et
inédit contre des individus sans et
casier judiciaire on accueille sur ce
plateau une nouvelle invitée ninon us
bonsoir vous êtes chef d'equipe au
refuge spa de plaisir alors les caméras
de 6,8 ont tourné un documentaire
entièrement sur place est la première
partie a été diffusée vendredi dernier
la prochaine sera diffusé ce vendredi à
21h on en parle juste après parlons déjà
dû
long de l'été pour le refuge spa alors
ça a été une saison assez difficile en
raison du grand nombre d'abandons
cette année ce sera tout à fait on
appréhende toujours à l'arrivée de l'été
dans les revues dans tous les refuges en
ces associations est la même partout
cette année on a en a recueilli en trois
mois on a recueilli 600 animaux c'est
une période où il ya peu de l'adoption
et on est extrêmement sollicité pour
dumont d'abandon et on se retrouve voilà
c'est assez démunis on essaie de pousser
les murs et d'accueillir le maximum
d'animaux c'est beaucoup de travail pour
les agents animaliers nos bénévoles
voilà mais là on a un bilan plutôt
positif dans le sens où voilà on a bien
tenu les adoptions reprennent et depuis
à peu près depuis mi-août donc une
minute les adoptions reprennent et les
juillettistes sont rentrés de vacances
et sont venus va nous aider à soulager
notre refuge et pia nous permettre
surtout d'accueillir d'autres animaux
qui étaient en attente d'abandon qui
avait besoin de sortir de fourrière
comment il explique qu'il y ait à chaque
fois cette recrudescence d'abandon au
moment de l'été travers les abandons
tout le long de l'année
mais la période des vacances
physiquement c'est l'occasion pour des
personnes qui ne s'organise pas qu'ils
n'ont pas anticipé la présence de
l'animal avec eux pendant leurs vacances
c'est l'occasion dû trouver quelques
fois beaucoup de défauts et puissent se
dire bon ben voilà on lâche prise on
renonce
on l'a pas bien éduqué mais y avoir des
raisons aussi sociale financière il ya
toutes sortes de raisons de raisons mais
du coup physiquement ça c'est dur ça
c'est dur parce qu'on se retrouve
quelquefois devait faire patienter les
gens qui sont en situation sociale très
compliquée qui ça arrache le coeur d'
abandonner leur animal
et comme les animaux sont saturés dans
l'est sont les reflets fourie à part
dans son saturé d'animaux laisser
lâchement sur la voie publique
ces animaux là prennent la place de
pertes d'animaux qui sont dans les
propriétaires sont dans une grande
détresse donc mon travail cdd aussi ces
personnes et on essaie de le faire le
mieux possible la situation du refuge
aujourd'hui qu'elle est elle vous disiez
les appeler par dont les adoptions ont
repris depuis la mi-août ça se poursuit
ça se poursuive où il ya eu encore il ya
eu plusieurs un bon week end
certainement que effectivement l'effet
de la mission sur ces 8 à porter ses
fruits pour le week-end qui vient de
s'écouler plus de trente chats plus de
dix chiens ont été adoptées dans le
week-end donc ça nous fait vraiment une
bouffée d'oxygène c'est un excellent
coup de pub pour paul refuges si bien
sûr et c'est l'occasion aussi de montrer
le travail qui est fait par les agents
animaliers il travail des bénévoles et
comment fonctionne un refuge un petit
peu et voilà toutes les personnes qu'on
peut y rencontrer les personnes qui
viennent abandonné abandonné mais aussi
les gens qui viennent adopté ce que vous
avez des retours positifs les gens ce
week-end vous ont parlé de cette
diffusion du documentaire et beaucoup de
compliments et eurent beaucoup de retour
aussi sur le facebook du du refuge
donc c'est plutôt positif ça nous
encourage à continuer dans cette voie là
et ça reflète le travail qui est fait
dans tous les refuges de l'experte donc
ça fait une petite lucarne
la 2 sur notre travail voilà un petit
focus sur notre travail et ça c'est
valorisant et ça permet voilà de mettre
en avant les animaux qu'on à l'adoption
et c'est très important c'est plus
important c'est aussi important de le
préciser le refuge spa de plaisir c'est
l'un des plus importants de france en
termes d'adoption c'est ça quand un ado
sion en termes de capacité aussi on a
des locaux qui ont été rénovés ya six
ans donc évidemment commentait dans les
images c'est un bon refuge mais qui
demande de l'entretien les animaux
abandonnés voilà la couleur des murs y
s'en moque un donc c'est plutôt le soin
porté par les équipes des agents
animaliers qui est très important et le
soutien des bénévoles
mais effectivement voilà on a la chance
d'avoir des parcs de détente c'est quand
même un environnement favorable on a une
capacité de plus de 200 chats et de 110
chiens et c'est une capacité voilà on
est toujours au maximum de nos capacités
d'accueil pour sauver plus animaux
possible on en récupère les animaux de
corse
cette semaine on récupère on récupère
des animaux d'une sortie de fous rires
de province la semaine prochaine on
récupère des animes de fous rires d'une
fourrière du sud d'accord on voit ça
arrive constamment et on va récupérer
des chats aussi qu'est ce que vous
espérez que la diffusion de ce
documentaire est ce que j'espère que ça
va sensibiliser aussi les personnes sur
cette question de l'abandon des animaux
sur à la fois voilà le geste d'
abandonner son animal alors qui a
peut-être peur des solutions en amont et
surtout de réfléchir avant d'acquérir un
animal vraiment notre disponibilité les
bonnes raisons au point qu'elle en prend
non pas pour faire seulement plaisir aux
enfants parce qu'on oublie tout le reste
à ce moment là et c'est là que c'est
qu'elle en général ça peut mal se
passait mal se finir pour l'animal et
puis de montrer aussi le principe de
l'adoption responsable on voit les
agents animaliers conseiller les
adoptants venir s'ils ont déjà un animal
venir avec leur chien qu'on puisse
tester les animaux ensemble ça c'est
très important parce que nous l'adoption
la voix sur le long terme
donc c'est important de faire a vraiment
un travail de conseil en amont et
d'orienter les personnes vers un animal
qui leur correspondent au temps bien
autant au chac aux chiens voilà c'est le
travail des agents animaliers les
caméras tv soit 118 ont eu l'occasion de
se rendre à plusieurs reprises sur le
refus de la les caméras de cfoot aussi
sur place comment réagissent et les
animaux avec la présence de toutes ces
caméras ça va il avait choisi un titre
ils sont plutôt habitués maintenant non
mais ce qui est très drôle c'est que
quelquefois quand les preneurs de sons
qui approche le micro donc c'est une
grosse masse comme commune qui goûta
comme un doudou et du coup certains
chiens ça peut effectivement dit peu les
excités essaie d'attraper les micros
mais sinon il se comporte très bien et
et voient ils font de très belles images
ils sont très photogénique on précise
deuxième partie de ce documentaire qui
sera diffusé ce vendredi à 21h sur
8 peut-être un mot sur l'adoption pour
terminer les conditions pour adopter
quels sont tes leçons ces conditions
alors pour l'adoption d'un chien demande
une participation de 300 euros pour un
chien de 300 euros pour un chiot 250
euros pour un chien adulte 150 euros
pour un chat les animaux sont identifiés
c'est très important
les animaux sont vaccinés et stérilisés
c'est important on y lit beaucoup pour
la stérilisation des chats
principalement des chats errants
également donc c'est aussi une activité
avait exercé par le refuge stériliser
les chats errants pour éviter la
prolifération nombreux chatons sont
décédées de maladies parce qu'ils sont
accumulées dans l'est dans les
fourrières dans les refuges
donc effectivement c'est important si
alizée les animaux pour éviter les
portes et non assumée qui se retrouvent
lâchement abandonnés dans des cartons
devant les portes des refuges mais
comment ça se passe on peut venir
directement sur le refus il faut prendre
rendez vous au préalable fut l'accueil
les visiteurs pendant les horaires
d'ouverture et personnes viennent avec
une pièce d'identité un justificatif de
domicile
et puis effectivement monde un petit peu
leur contexte on pose des questions ils
nous posent des questions bien sûr et on
passe du temps avec eux pour les
orienter au mieux et à fond qui repart
avec l'animal qui leur conviennent et
toutes ces informations on peut bien sûr
les retrouver sur le site internet de la
spa de plaisir qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci ninon lui est d'avoir est
avec l'ancien chef d'equipe au refuge
spa de plaisir culture avec un nouveau
visage pour la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt pour cette nouvelle saison
elle devient la commanderie un lieu qui
doit répondre notamment aux attentes des
jeunes samedi l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines lançait le premier
trimestre de sa saison culturelle
mélanie poker
elle la commanderie d-will comme le site
historique sur l encours fait peau neuve
pour sa nouvelle saison une saison
multiculturelle en y mêlant danse
rencontres musicales ou encore ateliers
scientifiques un fab lab enfin une sorte
d'incubateur qui va permettre quelques
expérimentations abu d'innovation
champions culturel donc toujours dans le
terme de créativité
en plus on va mettre
quelques thèmes un peu plus sur sur
l'activité ou sur le haut sur la
discipline scientifique et technique
les nouvelles technologies deuxième vie
sur avec des nouvelles étant de nos
jeunes aussi donc c'est pour ça que vous
avez toute une ambiance
musicale
très ciblé aussi un buzz ces populations
de la musique avec un dj parisien des
démonstrations de danse et un café
éphémère pour se restaurer un avant goût
d'une saison qui fonctionnera au
trimestre nous allons faire des
programmes de trimestre en trimestre ce
qui nous permet d'ajouter des actions
des événements qui soit différente de ce
que nous au programme avec des
partenaires que ce soit des associations
des compagnies ou les collectivités
locales intéressées
donc on a pensé par exemple organiser
des marches et circuits courts pour
permettre aux gens qui passent en
voiture tous les jours de s'arrêter
faire leurs courses elle la commanderie
reste aussi un lieu d'exposition pour
débuter ce premier trimestre c'est le
design européen qui est mis à l'honneur
avec une quarantaine de pièces issues
des collections du musée de la ville et
c'est justement cette exposition sur le
design européen à la commanderie qui le
coup de coeur culture de la semaine pour
en parler mélanie poquet bonsoir quand
ça on l'a vu on a vu quelques images de
l'exposition mélanie une quarantaine de
pièces de mobilier seront présentés et
oui c'est un saut dans le temps qui vous
attend la commande est alors pas au 12e
siècle qui est la date de la fondation
du site on va un peu moins loin plutôt
dans les années 60 70
ce sont les plus représentés dans
l'exposition une quarantaine d'oeuvres
qui vous fait découvrir cette époque il
a fallu choisir parmi les trois mille
oeuvres de la collection du musée de la
ville après guerre le mobilier
l'électroménager se caractérise par une
forme de fonctionnalités de rationalité
et à partir des années 60 il ya une
remise en cause de ce nationalisme et là
le le design oriente des voies nouvelles
beaucoup plus
pop et joyeuse dans son expression
plastique esthétique avec des formes
très coloré
des formes originales qui remettent un
petit peu en question les moeurs des
formes originales c'est le mot mélanie
oui c'est si comme oz fait ça tirée par
le mobilier classique il ya de quoi être
surpris alors on peut y découvrir des
lampes en forme de gélules de pilules
des poubelles qui sont penchés on peut
même s'amuser à deviner à quoi sert
l'objet exposé et son présente des
oeuvres des grands noms du design
européen et or et se classe par exemple
un magistrat ti en france on peut citer
alors le plus connu sans doute me suis
dit stark instar de ses dix mille
créations à lui tout seul c'est quand
même les plus grands designers france
est sans doute l'un des plus grands
designers contemporains au monde alors
l'exposition a débuté le samedi 8
septembre elle est à découvrir dans la
chapelle de la commanderie
l'entrée est libre du mercredi au
dimanche de 14h à 18h et ne tardez pas
pour en profiter elle se termine le 30
septembre
merci mélanie rendez vous juste après ce
journal c'est ça pour la reprise de
votre émission le 7-8 culture est un
nouveau jour en cette nouvelle saison
c'est désormais à tous les mardis avant
de se quitter
des poneys ont envahi saint quentin
l'espace saint quentin pour les trois
premiers samedis de septembre des
initiations équestre se déroule au
centre commercial à montigny le
bretonneux découverte de cette activité
avec vous mais l'anip ok mais aussi
marylène agat chisinau il s'appelle
atchoum britney et spider man et tous
les trois se font une sortie au centre
commercial c'est samedi du mois de
septembre
leur mission faire découvrir leur
univers aux plus petits
c'est un sport de plein air il apprend à
l'enfant à être altruiste puisqu'il va
vraiment s'occuper d'un animal vivant
il ya un contact avec l'animal que les
autres sports non pas forcément
et c'est ça qui est très important la
nature l'animal et le le don de soi un
peu c'est d'apprendre que les connaît
les enfants apprendront comment on
s'occupe du poney de sa nourriture
jusqu'au passage le club sky équitation
accueille les petits dès l'âge de 2 ans
pour des cours hebdomadaires mais
également des stages ponctuels pendant
les vacances je trouve que c'est très
bien pour faire découvrir un petit peu
l'univers
du poney d'équitation aux enfants que
c'est une bonne première approche
c'est plutôt sympa couloir à venir voir
les poneys pendant qu'on fait un petit
tour avec les petits et pouvoir
découvrir un petit peu tout ça après les
explications la balade dans les allées
de l'espace saint quentin et pour les
plus petits un parcours rien que pour
eux sur des poneys
parfois aussi capricieux que le vrai est
la fin de ce set 8 journal replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile n'oubliez pas dans quelques
instants
elle place au premier set 8 culture de
la saison est belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]